- [Sal] Let's study the
market for soda a little bit.
And so, we're going to
draw our traditional axes,
so that is price, and that is quantity.
And we have seen our classic
supply and demand curves.
So, this could be our
upward-sloping supply curve
at a low price.
Not a lotta people wanna produce soda,
but as price goes higher,
more and more people
would wanna produce it.
And we could also view that
as a marginal cost curve.
That first unit might be
quite easy to produce,
but then it gets a little
bit more and more expensive
or costly to produce as
you have to hire and train
more people and get real
estate for your factories.
So, you could also view this
as a marginal cost curve.
And then, on the demand side,
we have our classic downward-sloping curve
at a high price.
Not a lotta people are
gonna want the soda.
But then, as price gets lower,
a lot more people are gonna want the soda.
So, this is our demand curve,
which we could also view as
a marginal benefit curve.
That first unit of soda,
someone's going to get
a huge benefit for it,
and so they have a high
willingness to pay.
And then every incremental unit,
people might just get a
little bit less benefit,
and so they have a little
bit less willingness to pay,
which makes this downward sloping.
And so, we have our,
this, we could also view as
a marginal benefit curve.
And we have, and this is all review,
you would have your equilibrium quantity
that the market would produce
and the equilibrium price.
But now, I'm going to introduce a new idea
because everything we talked about here,
the marginal benefit and the cost,
this was just the marginal private benefit
and the marginal private cost.
It's not factoring in
society's benefits and costs.
And so, let me relabel this a little bit.
Instead of just saying marginal benefit,
I'm gonna call this the
marginal private benefit.
And instead of marginal cost,
I'm going to call this
the marginal private cost.
And this is the equilibrium price
we would get to if we just factored
in the private the costs and benefits.
And this is the equilibrium quantity
if we just factored in the
private costs and benefits.
And so, I know what you're thinking,
so that's nice, Sal, but how do we
factor in the social benefits or costs?
Well, for something like soda,
you could have some negative social costs.
And when you have negative social costs,
you would call that a
negative externality.
So, there are some negative externalities
when you are thinking about soda.
It could be that the cans cause pollution
that has to be cleaned up by society.
It could be that all
that sugar or corn syrup
inside of people's bloodstream
gives 'em diabetes or decays their teeth.
And society's going to
have to pay for it somehow.
And so, another way to think about it is
we could add those negative externalities
to the marginal private cost,
and we could get a
marginal social cost curve.
And so, let me do that.
So, if we add the negative externalities,
we get a marginal social cost curve.
So, this factors in the
negative externalities.
So, I'll call this the
marginal social cost.
And let's say, for a soda,
the private benefit, just for simplicity,
is equal to the social
benefit on the margin.
So, I'll say this is the same thing
as the marginal social benefit curve.
But now, if you think about it
form society's point of view,
what is the optimal price and quantity?
Well, then you wanna think
about where marginal social cost
is equal to marginal social benefit,
because if you produce,
you wanna keep producing
as long as the social benefit
is higher than the social cost.
But then, when the social cost is higher
than the social benefit,
well, then that's not good.
Then you're going to
create negative benefit,
or harm, to society.
So, it'd be rational to
produce up to this quantity,
this quantity right over here.
So, this is the optimal quantity
from a societal point of view.
And this would be the optimal price
But if you just let the private markets
happen as they are, what happens?
Well, then you're overproducing
from a societal point of view.
And if you think about it
from a societal point of view,
this is what is optimal,
but you produce all this quantity
where the marginal social cost is higher
than the marginal social benefit.
And so, all of this is going to take away
from society's benefit, from
the total surplus for society.
And so, this is going to
create deadweight loss
because these quantities are different.
Now, we could also think about a scenario
with positive externalities.
Let's imagine the exercise,
let's say the, I don't know,
exercise equipment market,
exercise equipment market.
We could draw similar curves.
So, here, we have quantity,
we have price,
we have our marginal
private benefit curve,
which would be our demand curve,
so marginal private benefit,
and we have our marginal
private cost curves,
just like that, marginal private cost.
And if we just let this market operate,
just thinking about the
private cost and benefit,
we would produce that quantity.
And I'll say that's just considering
the private side of things.
And we would be at that price.
But let's say that there's
a positive externality here.
So, there's a positive externality.
What is it?
Well, the more exercise
equipment that's out there,
the more people that are gonna exercise,
it's going to make them happier,
it's going to lower
their healthcare costs,
and so we would wanna add that benefit,
that positive externality,
to the marginal private benefit curve
to get the marginal social benefit curve.
So, let's do that.
So, we're gonna add to this,
and we're going to get the
marginal social benefit curve,
marginal social benefit.
And let's say the marginal social cost
is the same thing as the
marginal private cost curve,
marginal social cost right over here.
So, if you think about
what's optimal for society,
society should want more
and more exercise equipment
to be produced as long as
the marginal social benefit
is higher than the marginal social cost.
But as soon as the marginal
social cost gets higher
than the marginal social benefit,
then that makes no sense, that
would create negative value.
And so, what's optimal for
society is to produce up to that.
So, this is the quantity
that's optimal for society.
This is the price that's
optimal for society.
But if we just let the
private benefit and cost
be what decides the
equilibrium price and quantity,
well, we're only going
to produce this far.
So, from a society point of view,
we lost out on all of this quantity
where the marginal social benefit
is higher than the marginal social cost.
So, you have this deadweight
loss right over there.
So, the big takeaway here is,
when you factor in negative externalities
or positive externalities,
you might discover
deadweight loss to society.
And so, an interesting question
is to think about how
could society rectify that.
And there are ways to start
to at least approach it.